hey God's not dead april fools it is
weird though isn't it like if you're
gonna make a propaganda piece why
release it on April Fool's Day just
marketing wise it's a really strange
call God's not dead too so God's not
dead - is the conservative Christian
propaganda piece about a teacher who
mentions Jesus in the classroom and in
the school district tries to fire her
six of her guns she's like I didn't do
anything wrong so the case goes to court
so now it's a court movie ultimately and
as I say it is a propaganda piece
propaganda doesn't necessarily mean bad
for a movie there are movies out there
that technically fall under the
propaganda umbrella that I think are
well done movies however on the reverse
for the case of God's not dead -
propaganda doesn't actually mean good
either so the problem with this movie is
from the get-go they start villainizing
the other side they start villainizing
atheist and in the court movie I liked
seeing balance [ __ ] I liked seeing you
know justice with the blindfold and the
sword and the scales actually go to work
but in this movie it's like this girl
her brother died and then her family's
like hey can you get his [ __ ] out of his
room yeah thanks so she talks to Melissa
Joan Hart scare achter Melissa Joan Hart
scare achter talks to her dad and she's
like oh I can't believe they're so over
it he's like well that's the thing about
atheist atheism doesn't take away the
pain it just takes away the hope I'm
like that's unfair I'm just saying man
I've never known an atheist elusive when
really all right get his [ __ ] out of his
room I'm done I'm just done I may have
heard about a few [ __ ] who have done
that but just their dicks at that point
has nothing to do with their belief
structure or maybe they're grieving
maybe they're just dealing with it in
different ways I don't know from that
I'm just saying this happens at the
beginning so now the audience was like
eh theists are [ __ ] and the prosecuting
attorney against Melissa Joan Hart
stalking to her lord he's like I hate
people like your client what they stand
for they need to be stomped out - one of
the problems with this movie is when you
start villainizing people you have to
clearly make someone a dick and clearly
make someone a victim for the sake of
your agenda you start like logic has to
go out the window now one of the first
things you notice about Court movies
when people start saying well what do
you think would have happened what do
you think would have happened it even
happens in here on one side of it where
the other guys like objection
speculative the judges like
a stained watch it however when mr. they
need to be stomped outs
talking to someone up there and they
need to make him a dick he starts saying
like what do you think would have
happened with that what do you think
would have happened with that no one
says objection speculative because he
needs to be an [ __ ] in this moment
for the sake of making him a villain for
the sake of the story and while any
movie out there has moments where logic
does go out the window for the sake of
making a villain a villain in a
courtroom propaganda piece is just much
more noticeable and the whole concept of
this movie is just strange to me because
I feel like it could have been solved if
Melissa Joan Hart character just used
logic and reason if she just used the
argument like oh yeah I mentioned Jesus
because this student says so Jesus's
teachings was like Martin Luther King's
teachings or it was Gandhi or something
like that and I was just like yeah they
are similar that's pretty much what she
said so at that point you can make the
arguments like well I was just
addressing the religious belief of
Martin Luther King jr. and the
similarities and comparisons thereof
between the teachings of Martin Luther
King jr. and the one he followed at a
religious level however you got to make
this movie happen so that argument never
comes up when no one ever asks Melissa
Joan Hart side of the story of what
happened they were just like did you
mention Jesus yes I love were you
thinking suit I'm Court it just makes me
pull back and just be like I don't know
that it would happen that way you can
look up on Google stories about teachers
who have gone through some [ __ ] because
they teach Jesus in the classroom but
generally speaking I found that they
more or less start getting more cermony
she was never really sermon e in this
movie and that just feeds into the point
of this movie is an agenda they were
like well D doesn't matter Jeremy we're
making a point here stop with the logic
and then the movie goes into this whole
fear-mongering thing where this other
now because this is happening pastors
need to send in their manuscripts or
some [ __ ] and then this guy's like we've
been ignoring this for too long and now
it's upon us today we have to do this
tomorrow it's gonna be persecution and I
know that was my villain voice but this
dude was just straight up saying it like
guys this is gonna happen so Britta -
the movie is telling the audience guys
this is gonna happen maybe they're
setting up for this sequel I don't know
one of the pastors in the movie goes so
far as to be like we're at war
holy [ __ ] I just a bulb phrase I feel
like it's meant to scare the [ __ ] out of
people so you probably shouldn't use
that I'm just saying unless there is a
more Christian followers of mine like
you do you feel like you're at war I'd
like to know at this point cuz that dude
said you're at war and the Melissa Joan
Hart at a point in this movie gets this
crazy brilliant idea for her lawyer
she's like let's just prove Jesus was
real in her court so at that point I was
just mentioning a real dude
so they get all these authors I believe
the author's played themselves I don't
know the author's faces so I have no
idea but this is you know someone who
wrote the case for Jesus or something
like that just a few others they're all
like yeah he had to have existed and
it's in a movie about court I would have
liked who's seen the other side like why
not have the prosecuting attorney be
like oh god this is why he didn't exist
it's kind of the fun of court movies is
seeing both sides go at it with logic
and reason and facts and evidence not
the fields no one gives a [ __ ] about the
fields in the courtroom this is a
classic case of a couple things one a
character being written one way and then
acting another and two a character being
written a certain way and you not
utilizing that angle at all her lawyer
in this movie does not share her faith
she's like are you a believer do you
believe in Jesus he's like I know so I
thought that was gonna be a really cool
element in the movie they never explore
that whatsoever I thought he was gonna
be objective eyes he's really not and
that's proven by him going along with
this idea that she gets worse let's just
prove Jesus was real in court him not
believing Jesus was really you think
he'd be like no let's not that
let's not anything that in fact leave
the court stuff to me all right kiddo no
he's like oh that's a great idea that's
perfect let's do it if you were talking
about a real person then it's just you
referencing a real person brilliant I
just don't know why he not believing
Jesus is real would think that that was
a good idea it's like someone going to
most human beings you'd be like let's
prove in court that Voldemort was real
anyone brought that to my table and I
was a lawyer I'd be like get out now and
then will our spoiler alert I'm gonna
tell you how the movie ends yeah you
care they okay no you don't care so I'm
gonna say it means a courtroom movie the
end is solved from magic that's right
people pray and then she gets off and
you can say like well it's not because
then just shows people praying and then
she ends up being found not
or they rule in favor of her rather
rather than say not guilty let's not
have a goose down look someone makes a
phone call and someone makes a phone
call and then this guy who's a leader of
a band is at a concert he's like guys
all right I have a friend and she's in
court right now
so we all need to pray we need to pray
hard for her and everyone prays and then
it's like not guilty because everyone
prayed I did it just seemed like magic
it seemed really cop-out stupid in terms
of the narrative a movie why not just be
in a courtroom movie lock down your case
with logic and reason rather than having
prayers save the day why not make the
argument I made earlier in this video
guys in the end God's not dead - it was
just a blatant propaganda B's there's no
subtlety to the propaganda is you're
getting beaten over the head with one
side of an agenda and that just
irritates people just in general that
should irritate most anybody unless
you're making Passion of the Christ like
guys by the way you're in for two hours
of seeing this guy get his ass kicked
for the sake of Catholic girl period B's
style it's just it's annoying I wasn't
connected with the character I just feel
like this movie was a lot of missed
opportunities I didn't hate the movies
guts by the end I'm just saying it
wasn't good and I'm just saying I'm not
gonna remember God's not dead 2 and
t-minus one day ya already forgot all
right guys so here's a good question
what is your favorite movie that could
be construed as propaganda me Terminator
2 Judgment Day much more subtle than
this movie has a good message AI don't
go there whatever yours is comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you wanna see
more click right here to say more